hi welcome to plate to date my name is
Denise and today I have three gentlemen
making glances for me I cannot wait I'm
David I'm Ian I'm Andrew I am 97
Ashkenazi Jewish and my family
originates from Russia and Poland I
think that Jewish food it's really a
Melting Pot of different cultures
different types of food it really comes
from all around the world what I'm
looking for in a man being open-minded
is a big one I don't live a traditional
lifestyle I like just trying new things
I do things a lot by myself I did a
10-day silent Meditation Retreat I just
did it by myself and I go on adventures
so somebody that's open to trying weird
things I'm from Woodmere New York and my
background is pretty mixed my mom is
like Hungarian but my dad's side is more
Middle Eastern I'm not a big fan of the
American Jewish Cuisine which I feel
best saying that because everyone's like
you don't like pastrami but I'm like nah
like I I need my spice I need my kick
and they're like but what that
horseradish and I'm like no do you know
about like that's where it's at or Hari
so I want something that matches my
goofiness my athleticism and also like
intelligence so today I'll be serving up
vegan beef barreccas and the inside will
have mushrooms onions the vegan beef
crumble sauteed all together I'm sorry
guys I'm gonna need a moment with this
food get out of your phyllo dough for
any good barecca it doesn't matter if it
starts off messy Because by the end of
it it's going to be a beautiful
concoction just like me I have the vegan
just egg as you know the egg wash with
sesame seeds boom an oven here we go for
only eight minutes ain't that a treat
and these turned out just how I wanted
most people say Bon Appetit but in
Hebrew but they have on whoa it looks
like barricas
oh my gosh it is one of my favorite
foods ever look how flaky they are well
done
[Music]
oh yeah okay that alone I feel like
should win this I love it
oh
even if she doesn't love me that's all I
care about
so it's it's vegan meat or mushrooms I
do like that it's vegan I didn't even
realize it was vegan this effort tells
me that in a relationship he will pay
attention to detail he pays attention to
the little things and showing that he's
willing to put in the extra effort for
his partner I mean I guess it's above
and beyond emotional but to me like that
was pretty simple
I'm from Newton Massachusetts where a
third of the population is Jewish and I
am 100
Ashkenazi Jewish but I am not observant
so there is that strong sense of like
you don't have to practice the religion
you don't have to wear the yamaka but it
would be great if you could marry
someone who's Jewish and like keep that
alive number one thing I look for when
I'm potentially dating someone is
intelligence so I want somebody who like
I could talk to this person every day
for the rest of my life I think I took
something that was like pretty basic and
then I was like what are the things that
I love to put into all kinds of food
that I make I'm going to use like some
garam masala I'm going to use some
ginger because I can't use garlic and
onion so I'm just going to hit you with
everything else from all these different
angles
these may not be the prettiest glimpses
but I do think they're going to taste
pretty good in dating and food do you
want something that is visually
appealing or something with substance on
the inside for me I want substance
oh no
[Music]
but the flavor is gonna be good this is
my flavor Blends a flavor
it looks like an omelette it looks like
it's like a creative
he does his own thing got me got me
thanks these are a lot of things that I
would never think to put together but I
like I do like that in a partner I like
somebody that's willing to to try weird
and new things
the suspense is killing me just say if
it's okay or not
I like it yeah
flavor is really good it's not at all
what I would would expect a blitz to be
maybe he doesn't cook too often
I think he's busy I think he's a
creative type I think that he's he's
open to trying new things with a new
partner I mean he tried this is this is
a big thing to try he went for it no
fear let's go big and whatever happens
happens I mean yeah that's true and I
think he tried like
[Laughter]
I'm from Minneapolis Minnesota my dad is
an Eastern European Jew and my mom
converted and so technically I'm not
officially Jewish but I've been raised
Jewish my whole life Jewish people can
spot other Jewish people and there's
always like a sense of kinship between
us I'm looking for someone who is a
person to come back to at the end of the
day it's a busy world out there and
you're out trying to survive and you
want to be able to come back to someone
who's there for you so I made a pumpkin
spice Blitz try to just flip it
foreign
so this guy is a little rough here but
we are gonna fix him pumpkin spice cream
cheese in there fold that over and then
we gotta put him right back on the
burner we have our berry compote some
fresh berries around it
little dab of powdered sugar and we are
going to finish it off with three mint
leaves this is my pumpkin spice Blitz
yay oh my gosh that is beautiful I love
that little subtle like excitement there
is like a lot of genuine enthusiasm this
is beautiful plating he decorated it I
feel like maybe it's a family recipe oh
I feel like maybe he learned to cook
frozen yeah I actually learned the style
of improv from my Baba yeah maybe he's
close with his family that's true we'll
stalked him today actually here we go
they're so good oh okay all right this
is one of the tastiest things I've ever
eaten wow amazing okay I need a response
like that you're ready to step on the
glass look at this it feels like a
holiday
it's somebody that knows how to cook
definitely do you think she can cook
oh yeah I don't know how to cook
I'm gonna take another bite just for for
research purposes he's certainly a
planner he also probably tastes his
dishes so he's I did do that mindful of
the things he does I think that's a very
important characteristic for me and a
partner somebody that is attentive and
mindful I think she's going to want to
date Andrew because Andrew but see the
thing is I cooked a dessert David you
cooked like a full meal you know yeah
but she literally didn't want to stop
eating yours and she also liked your
napkins your silverware yeah it seems
like you cared the most which is
probably what she's looking for over any
of the food I'm gonna narrow it down to
number two which is flavorful Blitz
because he is open-minded and he's
willing to try new things and number
three because I'm also attentive to
detail and I like that I like beautiful
things and I like a partner that is
Mindful and notices things
I chose dish number two what
oh my goodness it was a little
I like that you just kind of took the
leap and you went for it yeah so now we
get to go on a date yeah and I was
thinking maybe I can cook for you which
will be an adventure and I'm making no
promises uh that would be awesome what
are you gonna cook for me great question
I don't know
[Music]